hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play amnesia
the great work okay we just finished up
chapter three and we just killed the
monster yeah so we are rolling
but what to rain on that parade someone
mentioned to me that um there's another
new monster that I'm going to encounter
very soon so I need to figure out how
the hell I got here wherever here is
and I'm guessing Samuel rescued me again
actually wait no hang on wait a minute
this yeah this is wait no yeah this is
this is the exact same place that I was
how the F did I get here what this
doesn't make any sense it's locked
that's what okay how the hell did I get
here
there's no reason for me to be here this
place is thoroughly ransack those
monsters are gonna nibble me apart
alright let's just get to Samuel he's
probably to get me Bryce sent me back
that way anyway the last moraines sob
hartleb was him running for his life
with a shard of the orb tucked under his
arm then a shadow passed between them
and all maurienne could see was imminent
dearth there's a clock ticking anything
Heather Heather and about it no okay I
don't I doubt there would be any more
items or anything like that available to
me so I'm assuming hey yeah there's
probably nothing here yeah no point dad
oh come on
Bob barley balls is a new one was I
supposed to do oh I could um I mean I
could have run past him oh I could have
gone into Samuels room I didn't know
that we're gonna spawn a moosh man
behind me was it bull a bull oh I get it
oh I get it okay okay so it was a
capture scene yes I is that you Samuel
you dick you captured me didn't you
uh-huh
whoa cannot see anything okay can you
speak up I can barely hear you
oh hello this is giant [ __ ] in my in
my cell that seems like a structural
abnormality huh call come on come on I
got to get that barrel that's it okay
how do I get it through here can I get
through here
yes I'm genius okay I'm a master prison
escape er I mean considering that almost
every amnesia custom story or most of
them have one prison so come on
I still don't trust you Samuel so how
about you got a file where are you when
I find you aha yes master escapist where
are you hey my jar come on give me my
dart oh come on I'm an idiot
Zhou wait hi there you are diving in
there while you're praying for me screw
you I don't even trust you I'm not uh
huh yeah whatever
uh-huh yeah that's good keep talking how
much oil I got not much fudge whoa whoa
I didn't do anything
Oh log down to them gimme gimme gimme
gimme I need that I burned myself on oil
so I'm an idiot or burn myself with an
ass anything anything else in these
cells that I need just weird chairs
sitting randomly okay what am I supposed
to do I don't know how to I mean I may
have been able to get out of my cell but
where do I go from here it's locked
baloney do I need to like find it key ah
I need to go beat up the grunt and get
the key from him cuz he's the key master
warden person oh hi dead guy nice
position to die in haha wait these
aren't my glasses Oh
anyone seen that photo oh never mind
that is this s looks special
my vision going a little wonky uh
Oh screw you buddy oh okay fine I found
a rich old dagger geez what does it do
the knife may be able to draw up other
liquids what are you talking like in
here
Why What okay not that draw up other
liquids wait wait what does that say a
knife that draws up blood through its
blade well there's a lot of blood down
there wait hang on is weird okay so not
that how about on this table okay I
gotta find something I need blood or
something I don't know I don't know okay
let's see I went down that way let's go
down this way
ah [ __ ] hell what the hell
Bologna I mean I heard him okay alright
get ready to throw down [ __ ] oh yeah
you don't even want him in my night [ __ ]
oh god fast get ready buddy
Bologna oh I totally I totes had him
bread I had him breathe
ah come on I'll leave my barrel still
here auch
God can't get through here ah there we
go okay that was easier ah baloney don't
burn myself
good good don't do that and I'm still
low on oil
okay still got the knife though um was
it think it was this way
yeah this way okay here's my chair yeah
there's my chair that was a dead end
over there so let's not go that way I
hear someone crying like little baby
stop being such [ __ ] is that you oh
you're dead at least you died like a man
okay I got a knife what do I do with the
knife I need to draw up blood with it
but it didn't work on the pit so I'm
assuming wait what oh that's the other
side of this uh-oh
question marks good sign Maureen had
been burned badly a portion of the East
Wing had to collapse as his partner lay
in bed recovering he glanced over at the
orb which still shimmered violently he
knew he could not allow Maureen to touch
it again oh boy everything went blue I
like blue lose a nice color I'm just
wondering if I'm gonna counter that new
monster again
actually you look more like a cultist
than anything you know damn and um I
don't have enough oil to go through here
see anything here it's locked
good I guess maybe I could get away with
not using it it's locked
good it's a dead end [ __ ] alright go the
other way seems like everything yours
dead-end or locked which doesn't help me
[Music]
okay haha alright let's go in the door
those just being smashed and yelled at o
lantern I already have you did you give
up no you didn't even give me oil I'm
back to two of those okay one of our
hearts has been stolen hard lip was able
to not able to find a way to destroy it
before he was killed
I thought I'm still alive oh he faked
his death that's right
sealed in vault tight safe here - sealed
in wire force okay so I think I think I
killed that one heart so there's more
hearts that I need to kill they need an
or blah blah blah
jump-scare know anything Inez probably
nothing probably nothing probably
nothing nothing nothing nothing
Oh Lana no now down it dumb yellow down
it down them awry
[Music]
I killed that [ __ ] huh I'll kill them I
totally killed that guy ha ha oh go away
I don't know if you bash down closet
doors boo boo boo boo boo boo boo bah
bah bah in the closet
[Music]
hi holy crap
you guys can't see but he's right there
[Music]
okay
please leave please leave I'm doing the
same thing here what's wrong with me
okay so oh yeah I read two other hearts
in the forest so I guess there are at
least two other of those things Podge
what was the point of even killing one
of them ah how do I get by him oh why
does that music start up no no okay I
gotta get around him somehow abalone
abalone oh just go for it go for it go
for cover cover
[Applause]
okay that was the wrong way to go it was
the wrong way to go that's the wrong way
to go oh that was the wrong way to go oh
that was the wrong way to go
oh locked yeah locked locked locked
everything is locked locked locked not
locked okay what is this
Oh whoa why was there a piece of whoa
hello why was there a piece of nard why
am i falling whoa I know what to do now
that's why I was given this time what
come on what no well what the [ __ ] Eric
hydroxide knife what why would they give
me a knife but that wasn't was I just
did that
I don't know okay what did that oh I
still have the orb
oh there was another one this is pieces
the orbs just lying all over the place
now of to what why what they just these
cultists just leave the pieces of the
orbs lying around here for anyone to
grab that would have been hard to hard
to I would've easily miss that one
[Music]
what's going on okay let's go okay so
why is the music so damn dramatic okay
so um hi hello it's someone there who's
knocking oh ah the goat I hate the goat
I guess I got to go find the nagas
there's something under here
well hon oh okay that look like anything
okay waste of time waste of time what's
it done up test you stupid boxes get all
the way who is knocking that's really
freaking me out
it's locked of course it's locked is
this like - it's locked
who's knocking oh [ __ ] I thought I saw
something
who is knocking why
it's select
[Music]
who's knocking who the [ __ ] is knocking
with knocking just tell me who's
knocking seriously I don't want to do
any more chemistry who the [ __ ] is
knocking at the door what the hell
Lily's bed why is this bed move what
what the hell what the hell what the
hell what the hell is going on what the
hell got a lover handle why do I have a
letter handle
[Music]
hmm okay why did that bit I'm in let me
get out here [ __ ] this [ __ ] everything
about this is the worst I don't like
this absolutely don't like this
[Music]
let me out let me out let me out let me
out let me out let me out oh no no no no
heart sab heart [ __ ] hearts we got
the heart why get the heart what are you
gonna do to me oh Jesus oh [ __ ] hell
now Oh piss Oh piss as a trap oh [ __ ]
Oh God Oh I've kind of relieved at least
I know it's gonna happen now I'm gonna
fall over and they're gonna better hold
your breath yeah okay wait what
[Music]
okay I moved out of there pretty easily
all right whatever I'm aw it's just okay
let's just calm down here buddy I need
to oh god it's not over yet Bob [ __ ]
hell
where am I going to go Brad I gotta go I
will stab the piss out of this heart
[ __ ] [ __ ] hell
go away you [ __ ] I don't wanna I don't
wanna I don't wanna I don't wanna I'm
dead I'm done I'm done I'm done
I'll pick this up I'll pick this up
later later much later I'll pick this up
later later later later later I'll pick
this up later I'll do this later I'll do
this later
I'll play it later okay thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
[Music]